sponsored by WB games welcome back to
inside Lego dimensions I'm Chris waters
and I'm Erin from game grumps and we are
going inside Lego dimensions it's like
the title says today it's doctor who
time who doctor who this guy the Time
Lord baby we are going in to the Doctor
Who level pack and there he is in all
his timely glory let's go ahead and jump
right in to the Doctor Who level these
guys don't look too friendly Daleks the
TARDIS is here never fear oh no buttons
I don't know how to use these oh jeez
gee whiz each level story of course
starts with one of these great cutscenes
not only setting the stage for the level
to come but also just like giving you
that fanservice of like here are some
Daleks playing basketball man like holy
crap expedite its Doctor Who in the
Dalek extermination of Earth all right
here we are I'm Peter Capaldi please
Scottish isn't he you can fix broken
Lego objects with your sonic screwdriver
get all these like mad Money's you know
what it's all about those purple and
blue studs though or high-value stud
sonic screwdriver that thing I will
continue the vandalisms oh the doors
open let's go fixed it that's because I
have the dr dot X on da mas des off oh
gosh oh no not not England ah jeez that
bus wow he just showed up it was like I
specifically want to blow up this one
part of town yeah whoa whoa whoa they
turned into Daleks got blasted got
certain to do this Kelly man you
definitely did Oh get in the Dalek
giving it oh no oh yeah you get some oh
gosh this is really fun this is actually
yeah there's this you know we had in
this in a Simpsons lovely pack there's a
similar situation you hop in a little
vehicle for a second and then there's
also elemental power that you unlock
later in the starter pack campaign
the TARDIS can dock on these tortoise
pads does that mean it sure does time to
build us a TARDIS
all right TARDIS do your thing I'm going
inside can I can I can I come I think
you might be able to as well excellent
I'm inside now it's warping space and
time wow I'm still clobbering Daleks but
meanwhile oh I think I can blue these
upper I'm coming in hey bud hey what up
it's time for your dog canine excuse me
TARDIS I'll just gonna have to push you
over here to ask your boy put it on here
this is how it's gonna save to that toy
tag Oh canine can destroy silver objects
oh look at that that's awesome press to
jump on canine and press that's a fire
oh whoa yeah what dog and move my robot
dog whoo we go yeah all it's the best
vehicle already this is by far the best
whoo bark bark bark bark woof woof woof
bark hey look at me go take us to a
different time spot right fine let's do
some time travel in time lord hello
toklas a poem trouble here we go
whoo-hoo it's TARDIS done baby oh cool
this is before the war I guess yeah this
is a way cooler place to be I am down to
four this place and i'm also down to--
i'm also down to be riding a little bit
of my canine buddy woohoo i will be the
Daleks I will destroy all of central
London this is how it happened on the
back of canine yeah yeah used to the
Daleks over there like well I guess if
he's doing it we could do it to other
they destroy it just seems to be a place
for everyone destroys things this is how
it happened whoa dude 00 Gandalf use
some magic over here how do we need some
Gandalf alone me let me build something
up real quick I don't know what it is I
think I'm repairing this truck oh nice
hey you should call for the doctor
techno panels hmm get technical use your
abilities where two discs and oh I am
Peter Capaldi
look at me I'm repairing stuff there's
Gandalf we're all friends here such a
lovely City this lawn dawg oh it planted
a nice tree oh look we're making central
London a lot more beautiful that is so
pretty I wonder if now that tree is
gonna be in full effect let's see what
our efforts have wrought in the year
3000 and disaster now that we're back
and I'm writing Arcana ah there's a tree
is it saved the bus it managed to
survive yeah the bus is still oh so you
wildfire you can jump up there cuz you
got them skills style wild style because
my staff yeah I'll protect you from the
king of the Daleks yeah I flipped on oh
wow okay babes messed up the bus still
owe still have a vendetta against the
bus yeah I don't see what I gotta get
across it's okay I I don't like cars so
you know we we all have our things whoa
holy cheese what is going on there yeah
we needed that that's a bad thing we
need to stick to your stealing
electricity from me
Alex no I will how you do this all day
keep doing it I was like wild styling
over here although we need to blow this
thing up this seems like a job for
canine over here Wow yeah even more
efficacious than I thought I just built
a scissor lift yes lift give a hoot oh
we caught on that just in time yeah you
you go ahead and investigate that area
oh I think I can i grab on that that's
who do you do it I'm gonna grab I will
repair this with my screwed I there we
go my favorite part of doctor who is
where he describes the actions that he's
doing at the moment right now I prepare
it is with my screwdrivers this is some
such nonsense he's Scottish man yeah
we're cool to repair this the accent
game it's a screwdriver what is the
secret that allows us to get it yeah I
don't know man this is the these are the
mysteries of Lego dimensions secrets and
secrets areas for you to explore maybe
something explodes all right what did
you what did you fix something over here
so we can move the TARDIS no tarda spot
all right hover TARDIS we definitely
have a lot more level ahead of us here
but instead I want to hop over to
another level and take Doctor Who back
into the starter pack levels to meet dr.
who what Oh stay tuned first of all he's
the doctor second of all let's do it now
I previously saved this checkpoint in
the Doctor Who level in the lego
dimensions starter pack and now it's
time to see what the doctor can do oh
snap what can the doctor do the doctor
can be really creeped out by weeping
angels is what the doctor can do you
know these things like you left to look
at them all the time cuz if you look
away their face gets angry oh no oh you
got angry faces oh no baby creepy face
that's something make them make them nut
swap places with me for eternity you
can't destroy them no you can't destroy
them oh boy I gee whiz I don't know hit
it hit it with something meanwhile the
doctor is just like
hanging out oh that's who we may be the
doctor oh yeah I think he can oh my god
the power keeps going out and he keeps
all right we need to feel like snow
moving yeah they keep poofing oh we got
to move these these platforms I think oh
happy bo days over here maybe over here
over here oh god stop their haul up yeah
she's like blocking my path now here we
go here we go did I'll take it from here
I don't know if we did the right thing
i'm not sure we did you what did well
gosh no no they've got us rose wick move
to another panel done they're flashing
easy odd smooth move it around come
around I don't think that went well do
we oh they took us out oh gosh no no oh
wow oh jeez oh alright it's got to be
careful with those again alright
wildstyle has discovered a place where
she can style uh wildly as she does and
it looks like she has revealed a thing
the Batman is gonna cut magnet back here
a more than ever here are the mega needs
you definitely hear the lego deserves
now this is the block we have to move
out of the way to not obstruct battery
gotcha so now we're in the battery over
that man is taking care of that business
man tech team don't worry about it hey
everything that you enjoy them and they
switch to Gandalf everyone everyone
pulls their weight candle don't push it
okay come on pick up a bit I'll just
stand there watching are you doing a
great job Gandalf I've got this Wow
raised John Farrell is older Gandalf or
the doctor the doctor okay uh see you
later weeping angels and see you later
Doctor Who starter pack of course
there's plenty more to dig into here in
the Doctor Who level pack including
upgrades for the TARDIS and k9 I'm
talking laser pulse TARDIS I'm talking
canine rough Rover and then of course
more shenanigans to get into in the
Doctor Who adventure world lots of stuff
to explore there
as always ah that was some sometime Lord
good time you think you're gonna sleep
okay tonight that was a good time lord
baby Oh set that up for you Thanks
nailed it knocks it down thanks for
watching inside Lego dimensions
you